Thank You dog for being here doc I've
been diagnosed with multiple cysts on my
kidney left kidney
hello I'm listening
multiple cysts yeah multiple cysts on
the left kidney
okay now motion no um did they find this
on a cat scan or MRI or an x-ray how'd
they find them yeah that's a little
sound okay and why were they doing the
examination did you have an injury on
your back or anything no I've been
itching I've been itching all over my
body for months and months and months
okay is this the first time this itching
has happened or that did you have that
when you're a teenager and a little kid
never
okay what about skin palms you ever have
any eczema dermatitis or psoriasis nope
okay what about asthma do you ever have
any asthma bronchitis
I've had several bronchitis bouts
okay I do emphysema okay and did you
ever have your appendix out or any bowel
problems no okay no constipation no
diarrhea no colitis no diverticulitis on
that No
okay sure what do you think is going on
here
well I don't know you could have a
gluten intolerance I've had several
bouts of bronchitis he's been itching
all over for months if you get what is
indicate of gluten intolerance and so
yes it's all over
definitely and in the history of again
bronchitis that can indicate a gluten
problem but the thing that's fascinating
to me
I met a guy the other night too both
kidneys covered with hundreds and
hundreds of cysts and he had been in a
car accident and they were doing cat
scans on him and they saw the assist
well these are usually birth defects
usually birth defects they're not
something that's acquired later in life
and they find them incidentally because
we're examining you for some other
reason okay and so all this becomes very
exciting for the doctor
oh my gosh we got to do a kidney
transplant we got to do this we got to
do that I would definitely get a second
opinion
when it comes to the kidney issue you
can have 25 or 50 assists the size of a
grape all of your kidneys and maybe have
been born with those and they really
have nothing to do with whatever your
health issue is you wouldn't see the
doctor for but there's something they
can hang their head on and you see it
it's very spectacular so anyway what do
you weigh here Glen well 150 ok
Charmaine what would you do in addition
to changing is that no fried foods no
processed meats no oils and glutens and
a wheat bread around oats
what would you a give Glen to support
healthy maintenance repair of all
biological functions the body personally
for his issues I just give him two
healthy brain and heart packs okay very
very good now you get an A plus plus
Tier two healthy brain and heart packs a
full dose everything twice a day and I
don't know I would throw in one more
thing I would throw in maybe the MSM I
just love that MSM for anything going on
in the body and so especially since he
had a history of itchy skin the dermis
which makes up like three-quarters of
the thickness of the skin is made up out
of a collagen connective tissue MSM is
wonderful for that supporting maintance
repair so I'd also I have Glen 150
pounds in addition to the two healthy
brain and heart packs full dosing twice
a day get two bottles a month to the MSM
from our free live division and take
three of those tablets twice a day give
us a call every couple of weeks if you
get a second opinion on those kidney
cyst and then find out what your kidney
function is if your kidney function is
all normal okay then I wouldn't worry
about it but get it another opinion and
get the numbers when you're Cranston E
and glomerular filtration rate let us
know